China's president Xi Jinping has met
with Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman in Riyadh on a quote pioneering
trip to open a new era of China's
relations with the Arab world that in
nashi's own words the visit issues first
to the kingdom in six years the two
countries affirmed their ties and signed
a series of strategic deals including
one with Tech Giant Huawei the Chinese
leader is expected to meet more golf oil
producers later
but for more of this we're now joined by
Andrew small and Asia expert with the
German Marshall fund here in Berlin now
the partnership between Saudi Arabia and
China what makes it so important
well first of all it's unavoidable that
the energy piece of the relationship is
is at the core uh this is
um this is critical to China at a time
in which
um the energy situation
um in the world energy pricing
um is is in a more difficult uh spot but
Saudi Arabia occupies an important role
across a whole series of different
dimensions of Chinese foreign policy at
the moment China always pursues a kind
of balanced approach to
um its diplomacy in the Middle East it
does have to balance its relationship
with Iran with Israel with turkey and
with with Egypt as the kind of
traditional Mainstays of its policy
there but Saudi Arabia is by far its
most important energy uh partner and
it's been a security partner in missal
um technology and sales going back a
long way so there is a security
Dimension to the relationship as well
and but it occupies an important role in
the Muslim World particularly when
China's navigating issues with xinjiang
and what's been playing out with its
weaker minority there so in that respect
Saudi Arabia matters a lot but in this
wider context of the struggle with the
United States kind of peeling away a
little bit traditionally close U.S
Partners I think is still understood to
be important to China it's positioning
across the whole of the developing world
and non-aligned world right now and even
in financial terms which is another
dimension of the relationship Saudi
Arabia matters in the context of
building a kind of resilient to
sanctions International Financial
architecture so Saudi Arabia really sits
at the center of quite a number of
Chinese foreign policy objectives right
now
well Saudi Arabia is one thing but
during his visit to the Saudi Capital
she is not just meeting Saudi officials
but also other Arab leaders like
Egyptian uh president Abdel fatah
al-sisi or Palestinian president Mahmoud
Abbas why is he doing that
well I mean first of all of course um he
couldn't just go to Saudi Arabia for
some of the reasons of political balance
that I I mentioned before
um but this is a context in which
certainly there is a kind of rebalancing
going uh on in the Middle East uh the
U.S pivot to Asia rebalancing away from
the depth of security role and the
importance of the energy relationships
in in the region uh means that China
although it doesn't want to step into
um the kind of role of the United States
occupied there are states in the region
that are looking to upgrade their
relationships this was underway already
of course for for commercial reasons um
but there is a sense in which China is
positioning itself to occupy a more
comprehensive role in the region in the
longer terms so all of these
relationships the golf Stakes Egypt and
the other cases as well matter uh very
much for the Chinese interesting in in
The Wider strategic context
from the German Marshall fund thank you
Andrew
thank you